اوقاتكم اهلا بكم الى اخبار الساعه نبداها
بابرز العناويه
[موسيقى]
المكتبات والمعاهد في وجه المراه
الافغانيه واشنطن تتواعد الحركه بدفع
الثمن
[موسيقى]
باتريوت تنقل ساحه المعركه من اوكرانيا
الى مواجهه بين امريكا وروسيا الاخيره
تتواعد بتدميرها و واشنطن تحذره من عواقب
وقيمه
حمى الاضرابات تصل الى فرنسا وتعطل حركه
القطارات اكثر من 200,000 مسافر تتعطل
رحلاتهم قبل الاعياد
امريكا تستعد لاسوء عاصفه القيم منذ اربعه
عقوده الغاء الفي رحله جويه يؤثر على
ثلاثه ملايين
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم لم تصمت المراه الافغانيه على
اضطهاد طالبان خصوصا بعد قرار منعها من
التعليم عشرات النساء خرجنا اليوم امام
جامعه كاب كابول احتجاجا على حرمالهن من
حقهن في التعليم في خطبه وصفت بانها جريمه
ضد الانسانيه لكن مع ذلك تسمى بالحركه على
نهجها في انتهاك حقوق المراه وطمس دورها
في المجتمع فبعد حضرت تعليم الجامعي اغلق
الطالبان في وجه النساء المكتبات العامه
والمعاهد النساء
كوره برشلونه
[موسيقى]
وقد تواعد وزير الخارجيه الامريكيه
بلانكانا بان طالبا ستدفع ثمن باهظا بسبب
قرارها الاخير بمنع النساء من التعليم في
الجامعه
الثمن القرار الذي اتخذته في حالي لم يتم
تراجع عنه لاملكه تفاصيل حاليا لكن نحن
بصدد تنسيقي مع حلفائنا بهذا الخصوص
واستطيع ان اخبركم انا محاوله طالبان
البحث عن اعتراف دولي وهو ما تريده لن
يحدث اذا استمروا في مثل هذه الاجراءات
وفي ايطار ردود الفعل المهدده ايضا بقرار
الطالبه نادانا وزراء خارجيه مجموعه السبع
بشده قرارات الحركه معتبرينها اضطهاد
الفتيات هناك يرقى الى جريمه ضد الانسانيه
كما ابدت رابطه العالم الاسلامي رفضها
لمنع النساء الافغانيات من حق التعليم
الجامعي وفي بيان لها اعتبرت الرابطه ان
القراري ينتهي كل قيم الدوليه والانسانيه
كما يحرم النساء والفتيات الافغانيات من
حقهن المشروع في التعليم وعموم الشعب
الافغاني من كفاءات نسائيه للاسهال في
ازدهاره
واحتجاجتنا على القرار انسحب طلاب جامعيون
من امتحاناتهم فيما قدم عدد من الاساتذه
استقالتهم من الجامعات بسبب قرار الحركه
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
الدوليه
فالحركه التي ظهرت والى التسعيليات من
القرن الماضي
في افغانستان خليفه عام
1994 والى الان تعيد دوران عقارب الساعه
عكس اتجاهها
حكم الطالبان افغانستان للمره الاولى في
الفتره من
1996 وحتى العام 2001 ووعدت حينها باحلال
السلام والامن والاحترام حقوق الانسان
بمجرد وصولها للسلطه لذلك ما لم يتحقق حظر
الطالبان مشاهده التلفزيون والاستماع الى
الموسيقى وارتياد الدور السينما ورفضت
الذهاب الفتيات من سن العا الى المدارس
ودخلت الحركه في عزله دوليه كبيره تمت
الاطاحه حينها بطالبان ولاحقتها تهم
ارتكاب انتهاكات لحقوق الانسان
ودخلت في حرب الواسعه النطاق ثم لا حسوا
الحركه مجددا خلال سنوات القليله الماضيه
في افغانستان حيث توفرت فرصه اخرى في ظل
محاوله الغرب دعمها وخلق مساحه للمفاوضات
عادت الحركه الجديده عقب انسحاب القوات
الامريكيه من البلاد العام الماضي
وبسطت سيطرتها بالكامل وفي خضم اعاده الدم
الحركه كان الحديث في ذلك الوقت المطالبه
بتقديم المساعده من المجتمع الدولي وفق
تعهدات للمجتمع الافغاني والعالمي وهي
تعهدات لم تحقق منها الحركه شيئا ومنها ما
تم مؤخرا من حظر الدراسه الجامعيه على
الفتيات
هو كان التاريخ يعيد نفسه من جديد اضاع
الطالبان فرصه من يدها وقطعت شوط اخر
للوراء عصام عبد السلام العربيه
اهلا بك سيد حمزه يعني ما هي الخيارات
امام المراه الافغانيه الان بعدما اغلقت
المدارس في وجهها والجامعات
تحياتي لكم
على ما اعتقد هذه القضيه لا تخص البر
الافغانيه فقط
هذه القضيه يعني تهتم بها كل المجتمع على
افغاني من الرجال والنساء
تربيه تسجيل القادم بيد النساء التي يريد
لها ان اا ان تجهل وان تبقى جاهله وبعيده
عن العلم والتعلم فلذلك على ما اعتقد انه
وكما نرى نشاهد في اليومين الماضيين انه
هناك ضغط كبير ومتزايد داخل المجتمع على
افغاني وهذا الطاقه بكل تاكيد سيؤثر على
قرارات الحركه كما نشاهد ان هناك يعني
شريحه من داخل الحركه ايضا ومن قيادتها
ومن قيادات الحكومه قيادات علي في الحكومه
ابدا ومخالفتهم لهذا القرار همم القرار
المحبط الذي يحبط الجميع اثار قلق الجميع
همم المراه الافغانيه يعني همم
لا يمكن لا قوه داخل افغانستان ان تقيد
المراه الافغانيه وتريد لها ان تبقى جاه
كان وبعيده عن العلم والتعلم وعن الثقافه
وعن همم
والرقي طيب فالمجتمع الافغاني مجتمع متين
ولا يمكن بهذا المجتمع ان يثاق بصوت همم
من جانب همم حكومه او حركه او افراد ااه
هذه العقليه مثل هذه العقليه طيب يعني لم
ااه يعني يغلق في وجهها فقط باب التعليم
ايضا طالبان لم تكتفي بمنع الفتيات من
دخول الجامعات بالقمع عناصر من الحركه
بالتردهن ايضا من المكتبه العامه في كابول
كجزء من انتهاكات طالبان ضد المراه قبل ان
نتابع حوارنا مع السيد حكيمه نتبع هذا
الفيديو الذي يوثق طردهن هناك
افريقيا
مال مراد
الخاصه بالنساء طردنا منها الضغط الدولي
هل سيغير راي الحركه ام ماذا
على ما اعتقد وهذا ما جربناهما في تعامل
الحركه مع المجتمع الدولي ان الضغط الدولي
لن يغير شيئا في عقلي الطالبان وعلى الاقل
عقليه الشريحه التي تفكر بهذا العقليه
وتريد ان تدفع المراه الافغانيه خارج
الحياه خارج مجالات الحياه من المجتمع
الافغاني
داخل البيوت
كما راينا وشاهدنا ان هناك تيار داخل
الحركه داخل طالبه ليس كله هو كل القياده
هناك طيار داخل الحركه هذا التيار مع
الاسف هم من يمسكون همم مقاليد الحكم وهم
يمسكون الصلاه وهم القاده العسكري يريد
ماذا يريد يعني اليوم همم
دول اسلاميه عديده تسمح للمراه بالتعليم
ما الذي يريدون
مع نسب هذا التيار عندهم الفهم التقليدي
الجاف من الدين المدرسه الدوبنديه
التقليديه الموجوده في شبه القاره الهنديه
ليس فقط في افغانستان بل بل بشكل اقوى
وبشكل اكثر تطرفا في افغانستان وعندها
هؤلاء الناس هذه العقليه عندهم وهذه
الفكريه عندهم وهذا الفهم همم عندهم من
الدين ان ليس للمراه ان تخرج الى المجتمع
وليس للمراه ان تتعلم وتعمل
وتلعب دورها في همم في ازهار المجتمع هذا
هذه هي العقليه عندهم وهؤلاء هم الناس
الذين يتمسكون يعني وهذا الامر يؤيد يعني
هذه همم المعلومه انه قبل ثلاثه اشهر فقط
تم انعقاد امتحان همم يعني امتحان الدخول
الجامعات تخريجيات المدارس وحوالي 30,000
من الفتيات تم قبلهن في الجامعات لكن
بمجرد تغيير وزير التعليم العالي
والتعين الوزير الجديد جاء هذا القرار هذا
القرار المحل هذا يعني ان هناك تيار داخل
طالبا لا تريد لا يريد هذا التيار للمراه
الافغانيه ان تكون ان يكون اي دور للمراه
الافغانيه لا في التعليم لا في الاقتصاد
لا في العمل لافي السياسه ولا في اي مجال
من مجالات الحياه
وهذا هو فهمهم همم من الدين وفهمهم من
الحياه الاجتماعيه شكرا جزيلا للسيد حمزه
حكيمي الناشطه الحقوقي كنت معنا من كاظم
[موسيقى]
لدينا ايضا في اخبار الساعه
اصيل تخوض معركه شرسه مع كورونا والقادم
اسود
[موسيقى]
حياكم الله من ارض المعركه في اوكرانيا
تحولت الحرب الى ساحه اخرى ساحه مواجهه
معتزنه بين واشنطن تصاعدت فيها لهجه
الاتهامات والتهديدات المتبادله روسيا
الغاضبه من زياره الرئيس الاوكراني الى
الولايات المتحده وجهت اتهام مباشره
بالتورطي في حرب اوكرانيا وشن حرب غير
مباشره على روسيا الرئيس الروسي رفع
اللهجه ليتواعد اليوم بتدمير منظومه
الامريكيه التي حصلت عليها كيف ردت واشنطن
على الفور باتخاذ اجراءات اضافيه ستكون
عواقبها وخيمه على بوتن
قديمه بما فيه الكفايه ولا تعمل كما تعمل
انظمه اس 300 مثلا ومع ذلك من يجاب هنا
ينطلق من ان هذا السلاح دفاعي سناخذ هذا
في الحسبان ببساطه وسنجد له تاريخا ومن
يفعل ذلك يطيل ام نزاع فقط سنحطم منظومه
الباتريوت وسيحتاج الغرب الى جلب اسلحه
اخرى
في المقابل قال وزير الخارجيه الامريكيه
لان بلاده عازمه على استخدام جميع
التدابير المناسبه لردع الهجمات الروسيه
على اوكرانيا جو او بحرا او برا وقال
لينكن ان بلاده مستعده لاتخذه اجراءات
اضافيه ستكون لها عواقب وخيمه على الرئيس
الروسي في هذه مربوطن وداعيه في الحرب
الاوكرانيه مضيفا ان روسيا لم تظهر اي
اشاره ذات معنى لانهاء الحرب في اوكرانيا
معنى من واشنطن هبه القدسي مدير التام
مكتب جريده الشرق الاوسط في واشنطن اهلا
بك سيده هبه يعني اليوم نتحدث عن هذه
اللهجه التصعيديه من قبل الرئيس الروسي ما
الذي يمكن ان تتخذه الولايات المتحده على
الارض وبالتالي يعني هذه المنظومه حينما
تسلم الى كيف لن تسلم في يوم غد بل هي
تحتاج الى تدريب اي اشهر
بيت الابيض اعلن انه سيتم تدريب القوات
الاوكرانيه في دوله سا- ثالثه وليس على
الاراضي الاوكرانيه لكن بالتوازي مع ما
اعلنته الولايات المتحده من تسليم منظومات
صواريخ باتريات هناك ايضا اعلانات من حلف
الناتو من جانب همم المانيا ودول عديده
اخرى وبالتالي هذا يعني ان انا امام صراع
طويل المدى همم تتعالى فيه صيحات التحذير
من الجانب الروسي ومن الجانب الامريكي
الجانب الامريكي يسر انه سيدعم سيستمر في
دعم كيف مهما طال الامر ومهما تكلف الامر
وبالتالي هناك في الكونغرس همم مشروع
قانون حول ما ما يتراوح ما بين 40 مليار
الى 45 مليار لمساعدات الى كيف خلال
الفتره المقبله وفي المقابل كما راينا تص
رئيس بوتين انه سيقابل هذه المنظومات
الامريكيه باتريوت باسلحه اخرى متقدمه
فبالتالي ورغم هذا التصعيد في التصريحات
هناك ايضا همم لهجه محاو يعني محاوله
لاظهار ان كل جانب لديه رغبه في التفاوض
ولديه رغبه في ارهاب انهاء الحرب وفي وضع
نهايه لهذه الماسيسي لكن ليس هناك ارضيه
لتفاوض او اليه للتفاوض حتى
المصطلحات مختلفه تماما ما بين روسيا وما
بين الولايات المتحده العدوان هل هو عدوان
ام حرب ام عمليات عسكريه وبالتالي يلقي كل
طرف على طرف الاخر باللون في استمرار هذه
الحركه
طيب هذه اللهجه بالتاكيد زادت بعد الزياره
وارجو ان تبقي معي بالحديث عن زياره
زرنسكي للولايات المتحده
وكم اغضبت هذه الزياره روسيا هي في
النهايه زياره غيرت قواعد اللعبه وادخلت
الحرب في اوكرانيا الى متاهه جديده موسكو
نامت على صوره زيننسكي وهو يتبادل التحايا
مع الرئيس الامريكي والاكثر من ذلك عودته
غانما بحزمه مساعدات جديده لن تزيد الحرب
الا استحقا
زياره حتى قبل وصول زين المسكين الى
واشنطن بل بمجرد اقلاع طائرته من بولندا
حيث قال ان في زيارتها جاهلا واضحا
للمخاوف الروسيه واتهم الكرم واشنطن
بالمشاركه مباشره في هذه الحرب هذه
الزياره تاريخيه الى الولايات المتحده
ساره قتل الانظار حتى من التطورات
الميدانيه حيث تركزت الاعين على
لترصد مشاهد الرئيس الاوكراني وهو يكرر
تحالفه مع الولايات المتحده ردود الفعل
توالت لكن كيف تفاعلت الصحف العالميه مع
هذا الحدث
مجله نيوزبيك شدادات على ان زياره زنس في
جاءت في توقيف جيد كما انها اشاره الى ان
الدعم الامريكي لا يزال قويا اما صحيفه
نيوز ويك ان نيويورك تايمز عفوا فقد وصفت
زياره الى الولايات المتحده تاكيدا على
وحده البلدين في مواجهه الهجوم الروسيه
يعني خلاص
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
اذا ذكركم بهذا العاجل انفجار قويه بمنشاه
غاز في مدينه المحمديه في المغرب وسلطات
تقول الله خسائر طيب نعود الى حديثنا عن
زياره المسكين الى واشنطن ومعنا منه
واشنطن هبه القدسي مديره مكتب جريده الشرق
الاوسط في واشنطن السيده هبه يعني الان
وبعد حديث الى
الكونجرس ومعتبره استثمارا في
الامن العالمي بينما تعتبره روسيا
استغلالا وحربا بالوكاله يبدو ان حتى في
الكونغرس الحزبان الرئيسيان في الولايات
المتحده كما يقال ليس على قلب رجل واحد
هناك تباين حول هذه المساعدات هل اقنعهم
الرئيس الاوكراني بتقديم هذه الحزمه
الجديده
لعبه الرئيس اللي نسكي على وتر هام في
حديثه الى الكونجرس بمجلسيه وهو ان هذه
الاموال وهذه المساعدات العسكريه
والاقتصاديه
ليست اموال خيريه وانما نوع من الاستثمار
الجيد وهذا الوتر هو ما يعني يطلق
الاروقه السياسيه الامريكيه بشكل كبير لان
نجاح روسيا في هذه الحرب يعني اعاده
لتشكيل وتحدي للاراده الامريكيه واعاده
لتشكيل توازن القوى والهيمنه الامريكيه
وتهديد الهيمنه الامريكيه فهو يضرب على
وتر هام يهمه الاداره الامريكيه والاروقه
الامريكيه بشكل عام هناك بالفعل كمال من
الجانب الجمهوري حول هذا التدفق الكبير
للاموات لكن هذا هذه الزياره التي تم
التخطيط لها
التي اتت في توقيت اا مهم للغايه وتنقيط
حرج مع قسوه الشتاء وقسوه العمليات
العسكريه ومعلومات استخباراتيه عن هجوم
عسكري روسي كبير خلال الفتره القادمه كانت
الرساله الرئيسيه فيها هي حث الكونجرس
الامريكي وبصفه خاصه الجمهوريين على
الموافقه وعلى تمرير
المساعدات لاوكرانيا من خلال استغلال هذا
الخطاب للنسكي امام الكونجرس ومحاوله
التوضيح ان هذا كل هذا من مصلحه الامن
القومي الامريكي من جانب اخر ارسال رساله
الى روسيا انه المساعدات ستظل متدفقه مهما
طال الامر ومهما تكلف الامر وبالتالي نوع
من الضغط على روسيا حتى تقبل
التفاوض لكن بشروط اوكرانيه امريكيه ومحا
للضغط على تنازلات تقدمها روسيا بشكل كبير
الامور تبدو انها ستستمر طويلا الى ان
يصرخ الحرب اغلى واقصر كلفه من تكلفه
التفاوض والمضيم قدما الى السلام
مدير مكتب جريده الشرق الاوسط في واشنطن
جزيل الشكر لك
[موسيقى]
اذا نتابع هذه الصور المتداوله لي التفجير
في منشاه غاز في المحمديه في المغرب طبعا
المحمديه تقع في شمال شرق الدار البيضاء
مراسل العربيه كان قد اورد لنا بان سلطات
المغربيه تقول انه لم تسجل اي خسائر بشريه
في حريق محمديه وان فرق الانقاذ تحاول
السيطره على حريقه هذه المنشئه منشات
الغاز في المحمديه نستمع الى هذه الصور
المباشر
صور المتداوله
[تصفيق]
طيب معنى ينضم الينا مراسل العربيه عدل
الزبير عادل ما هي التفاصيل حول هذا
الانفجار
وقع في اكبر في احد اكبر
شركه
تستورد هذا المطار من الخارج وتعبئه الى
غايه الان فرقوا الانقاذ منتشره ومتواجده
في هذه الحي همم المتواجد في مدينه
المحمديه المحمديه موجوده بين العاصمه
المغربيه الرباط ومدينه الدار البيضاء في
الشارع
الاطفائي عقارب الساعه من اجل محاصره
السنه للاب ومحاوله منع انتشار الحريق الى
خزانات اخرى لغاز البوتان لان مدينه
المحمديه تتوفر على ميناء تصل اليه
البواخر التي يستوردها المغرب من غاز
البوتان من الخارج الى
غايه جيل
اثريه في الارواح السلطات تحاول ابعاده
السكان من في المنازل والمناطق المجاوره
لمكان الحريق المعلومات الاوليه تشير الى
بدايه التحكم في هذا الحريق الذي نزل في
جاره مدينه المحمديه واخافك دويه السكان
ولكن المعلومات القويه الاوليه الشروطات
المغربيه مطمئنه فرق الانقاذ متواجده ومن
المرتقب في الساعات المقبله ان تتم محاصره
السنه هذا اللاعب اذا لم يتطور الحريق
خصوصا ان ال ال الاحوال الاحوال الجو
والطقس تساعد فرق الاطفائيين المنتشرين في
اي مكان وفرضت السلطات سياج معدني وحواجز
حديديه لمنع السكان لمنعهم للاقتراب من
مكان هذا الحريق الذي يعتبر واحد من اكبر
حرائق التي تعرفها عدل عريس تخزين غاز
البوتان في المغرب طيب عاد هذه المنشاه هل
تحوطها البيوت بيوت السكان ام هي بعيده
نوعا ما هل السلطات اغلقت الشوارع المؤديه
اليها وبالتالي همم يعني في محاولاتها كما
ذكرت بتطويق هذا الحريق
قريبه نوعا ما من المناطق السكنيه ولكن
هنالك مسافه امان كافيه بحسب الفرق
الميدانيه المتواجده في عيد المكان ما جعل
فرق الانقاذ تشتغل بنوع من الراحه لان كل
ما اقتربت هذه الميراث من السكان من خطر
كبير ولكن الى غايه الان حتى التلفزيون
المغربي نقل قبل قليل
اخبارا اكيد ان الامور الى غايه الان
فاتوكان لعدم الاقتراب من مكان هذا الحريق
الذي يعتبروا حريق كبير في منشاه حساسه
جدا لان الغاز سريع الاشتعال غاز البوتان
سريع الاشتعال وهو ما تكشف هذه الصور
المتداوله على منصات مواقع التواصل
الاجتماعي
في تاريخ مدينه المحمديه التي تعرف تواجدا
لهذه المنشات المتخصصه في تخزين غاز
البوتان المستورد من خارج المغرب الى غايه
المعلومات المتوفره مطمنه الفرق الميداني
لكن سائر بشريه وان الانفجار لم يتسبب في
وقوع اي ضحايا او شرح الى غايه الان في
انتظار معلومات
اخرى وتناول
نا ازمات المغربيه التي تنفذ الان خطه
ميدانيه لتسريع عمليه اخماد هذا الحريق
لحساسيه مكان الحريق بتواجد مجموعه من
نقاط تخزين وصهاري تخزين غاز البوتان لان
مدينه المحمديه هي مدينه تقديم غاز
البوتان في المغرب
لايضا المزيد من المعلومات
ونتمنى السلامه للمغرب شكرا جزيلا لك
[موسيقى]
حمى الاضرابات تصل الى فرنسا وتهدد
المسافرين خلال عيد الميلاد مئات اننا
رحلات رحلات القطار الغيت بسبب اضراب جديد
للمراقبين لعدم رضاهم رضاهم عن زياده
الرواتب الممنوحه بنسبه 12% على مدى عامين
الغاءه الترت على حوالي 200.000 مسافر
خلال عطلات العيد هذا هو سيتم تسير قطارين
فقط من اصل ثلاثه في عطله نهايه هذا
الاسبوع وابقى تقديرات الشركه الفرنسيه
للسكك الحديديه اطربوا عمال السكك
الحديديه لكن انتقادا حادا من الحكومه
الفرنسيه حيث قال المتحدث باسمها
المظاهرات والمطالب باجور اعلى امر مشروع
لكن لا يوجد تبريره لتنظيم اضرابات في هذا
التوقيت
هذا وتترقب بابريطانيا غدا الجمعه استئناف
الاضرابات بعد توقفها اليوم ما يهدد بخنق
الحياه العامه واصابه البلاد بشلنت حقيقي
فمستوى الاضرابات بلغ خلال شهر ديسمبر
الجاري مستوى قياسيا اذا شهد كل يوم
تقريبا من هذا الشهر وقفات احتجاجيه
وتعطيبا للعمل مطالب برفع الاجور ولا
تنحصر تداعيات الاضرابات في تعطيل حركه
المواطنين ولكنها تسببت في اضرار على قطاع
الصحه والمستشفيات بالاضافه الى التابعات
الاقتصاديه حيث اصدر مع هذه الشؤون
الاقتصاديه البريطانيه تقريبا يقدر فيه
خساره البلاد بنحو 300 مليون جنيه
استرليني يوميا نتيجه اضرابات شهر ديسمبر
[موسيقى]
معنا من طريقه مراسل العربيه حسين
من لندن مراسل العربيه مصطفى زارو اهلا
بكما يبدو ان اوروبا تودع هذا العام
بمزيد من الاضرابات حتى تشارك فيها حسين
ضعنا في صوره ما يحدث يعني الحديث عن
قطارات لم تتحرك من مكانها او مسافرين
تعطلت رحلاتهم عبر القطارات
نعم عادل مساء الخير انا هنا من امامي
محطه قطارات الثلازار في العاصمه باريس
وفي الواقع حركه الاضراب التي بدات عمليا
اليوم والتي ستمتد الى ليله الاحتفال
بالميلاد حتى الى يوم الخامس والعشرين من
هذا الشهر ستؤثر على 200,000 فرنسي تتركز
على قطاع القطارات السريعه
القطارات الفائقه السرعه التي تنقل
المسافرين عبر المدن الفرنسيه هو طبعا من
يقوم بهذا الاضراب هو المراقبون ومهمتهم
الصعود على متن القطارات للتحقق من ما اذا
كانت الراكب قد اشترى بطاقه سفر ام لا
هؤلاء هم المراقبون هم الذين دخلوا في
اضراب منذ ما قبل ساعات في الواقعه الشركه
الوطنيه للسكك الحديد كانت اصيبت بخسائر
بلغت ثلاثه مليارات يورو ابي خلال عامين
الكونا وقامت الدوله الفرنسيه بدفع مبلغ
اربعه مليارات لهذه الشركه كي تج- تتجاوز
خسارها وهذا الاضراب يدخل الشركه مجددا
بازمه عميقه معي سريعا احد الاشخاص الذين
يستخدمون القطارات السريعه
همم جوجل
من يتحمل المسؤوليه ما سيجري من اضرابات
برايك الدوله ام الشركه الوطنيه للسكك
الحديد امام المضرب
كمان
يعطلون الحركه
لا يضربون بلا سبب
جيده للعمل فانهم سيضربون الحكومه اذا
تتحمل ايضا مسؤوليه في هذا المجال هذا بعض
من الصوره هنا يضاف الى اضراب مراقبيه
القطارات السريعه اضرار جزئي هامشي لن
يكون له تاثير كبير ينفذه مضيفه شركه
اكدت ان جميع رحلاتها ستبقى قائمه عادل
حسين حتى الان ساذهب الى لندن وارى ماذا
يحدث هناك من الاضرابات وتاثيرها على
الشارع البريطاني خلال فتره همم العيد
وهذه وهذا التوقيت الهام بالنسبه
للبريطانيين مصطفى
عادل يعود عمال سكك الحديد في اضراب جديد
هذه المره سيبدا ابتداء من الساعه السادسه
مساء من يوم السبت وحتى الساعه السابعه
صباحا في 27 من هذا الشهر ومن ثم هناك
سلسله اخرى من الاضرابات همم بدايه الشهر
المقبل هذه الاضرابات هي تدخل تدخل ضمن
التعنت نقابه عمال اسكاك الحديديه الذين
يطالبون بزياده همم اجورهم ولكن لم يعطوا
اي نسبه معينه شركه نت وورك رويال همم
قدمت ضمانات بان لا يكون هناك اي تصريح
الزامي بالاضافه الى عدم همم حتى عام 2025
بالاضافه الى عدم تغيير شروط العمل وكذلك
زياده اجور بنسبه 5% هذا العام ومن ثم
زياده اخرى بنسبه 4% في العام 2023 ولكن
نقابه ه
المضربين لم يكونوا لم تكن راضيه وبالتالي
همم يحاولون ان يكسب اكثر من ما تم طرحه
على الطويله هذه سلسله اضرابات يعني ليست
بجديده شهدناها في في الاشهر الماضيه وهي
فرصه ايضا للضغط على الحكومه من جهه وايضا
على مشغل القطارات هؤلاء الذين سيضربون
يمثلون او يعملون فيه 14 شركه تدير رحلات
القطارات من لندن الى مدن مختلفه وانا حيث
اتواجد في محطه همم فيكتوريا التي تربط
همم قطاراتها بعدد من البلدات وايضا المدن
في جنوب وشرق انجلترا ايضا هناك توقعات
بان همم تحدث همم اضطرابات لقوات همم
همم حفظ الحدود همم يعني همم ايميريشن
وفيسز بالاضافه الى اولئك الذين يتعاملون
مع التفتيش البضائع القادمه من خارج
المملكه المتحده سي- سيدخلنا في اضراب
ابتداء من غد لمده اربعه ايام ومن ثم
ستكون هناك همم سلسله اضرابات اخرى لاربعه
ايام لهؤلاء ولاربما ستحدث هذه الاضرابات
الكثير من الشلل خاصه في ما يتعلق
بالمسافرين القادمين من خارج المملكه
المتحده او اولئك الذين يحاولون المغادره
للاحتفال بعيد الميلاد وايضا نهايه راس
السنه
العربيه من لندن شكرا جزيلا لك والشكر
موصوله ايضا لحسين مراسل العربيه من باريس
[موسيقى]
من منشيها واليها يعود بيرس كرونا بقوه
الى الصين توقع تحليل الاخير ان تشهد
الصيني يوميا مليون اصابه 19
فايروس في الوقت الذي تكافح فيه البلاد
للسيطره على الوباء شركه اريفانتي لاعداد
التحليلات ومقرها لندن رجحت بان الموجه
حاليا قد تشهد زياده معدل الاصابات
اليوميه الى ثلاثه ملايين و700,000 شخص في
يناير المقبل وقدرت الشركه ان يكون على
الارجح هناك موجه اخرى من الاصابات من
شانها ان تدفع الدروه اليوميه الى اربعه
ملايين ومئه الف اصابه في مارس
في هذه الاثناء ابلغ مستشفى في شنغهاي
موظفيه بالاستعداد لما وصفه بمعركه
ماساويه مع فيروس كورونا حيث يتوقع اصابه
نصف سكان المدينه البالغ عددهم 25 مليون
نسمه بحلول نهايه العام وفقه روترز
[موسيقى]
لدينا ايضا في اخبار الساعه
مناشده لبريطانيا بوقف ترحيل اللاجئين الى
رواندا والحكومه مصممه
[موسيقى]
حياكم الله بعد تايد المحكمه العليا في
لندن ترحيل المهاجرين غير الشرعيه الى
رواندا يدرس ناشطون تقديم طعن في القرار
مطالبين الحكومه باعاده النظر في ترحيلهم
طالب اللجوء الكردي صباح حسن من بين الذين
يواجهون امكانيه الترحيل الى رواندا بعد
انقضت المحكمه العليا في لندن بقانونيه
ابعاد مهاجرين دخلوا بريطانيا
الى العاصمه الرومانيه
بشؤونهم عبروا عن قلقهم الشديد
ستكون امنه او غيره امنه هذه المجموعه
الكرديه من طالب اللجوء اتت لتستفسر من
احد اعضاء الجمعيه الكرديه لندن بشان
تداعيات تاييد المحكمه العليا لتسويه
طلبات الراغبين باللجوء على بعد الاف
الاجيال من بريطانيا
لحقوق الانسان
قبل ذلك فالمصار القضائي ليس نهائيا لهذا
قرار
الخطه المثيره للانتقادات بابعاد الاجئين
وصلوا بريطانيا بطرق غير نظاميه الى
رواندا تبنتها حكومه جونسون باتفاقيه مع
نظيرتها في كيغالي لوقف رحلات عبور البحر
الخطيره لالاف المهاجرين من فرنسا الى
الجزيره البريطانيه ترحيل اول دفعه من
ثمانيه لاجئين الغيت الصيف الماضي بعد
تدخل المحكمه الاوروبيه لحقوق الانسان لكن
وزيره الداخليه السولارما مصره على مواصله
سياسه الترحيل في اقرب وقت ممكن
تبيعات هذا القرار غير الانساني وفور وصول
اللاجئين لايوائهم قد ينقلون الى بلد لا
نعرفها
كسب وزاره الداخليه تاييد المحكمه لنقل
اللاجئين الى افريقيا للبث في طلباتهم
يضعوا على طريق تنفيذ خطتها التي لا تزال
حبر على ورق وكلفت دفع الضرائب حتى الان
120 مليون جنيه وقد تتطلب عده اشهر
لتنفيذها بعد انتهاء المسار القضائي مصطفى
زارو العربيه لندن
[موسيقى]
يجتاح الولايات المتحده انخفاض في درجات
الحراره يسبق عاصفه ثلجيه الكبرى قد تكون
الاقوى هذه الفتره من السنه من حوالي
اربعه عقود العاصفه تسببت في الغاء ما
يقرب من 2000 رحله جويه في الولايات
المتحده ومن شان هذا الالغاء هذا هذه
الالغاءات ان تربك المسافرين خلال عيد
الميلاد حيث كان من المتوقع ان يغادر اكثر
من ثلاثه ملايين مسافر مطارات الولايات
المتحده خلال هذه الفتره
[موسيقى]
وقفه وقفتنا مع ابرز احداث السنه وتحديدا
شهر مارس
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
اه لين اليوم
في هذه اللحظه التاريخيه
عن حل المجلس النيابي
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
نهايته اخبار الساعه تذكيرهم بابرز
عناوينها
بعد حظر التعليم طالبان تغلق المكتبات
والمعاهد في وجه المراه الافغانيه واشنطن
تتواعد الحركه بدفع الثمن
هات رياضه تنقل مساحه المعركه من اوكرانيا
الى مواجهه بين امريكا وروسيا والاخيره
تتواعد بتدميرها و واشنطن تحذروا من عواقب
وخيمه
ثم الاضرابات تصل الى فرنسا وتعطل حركه
القطارات اكثر من 200,000 مسافر تتعطل
رحلاتهم قبل الاعياد
وامريكا تستعد لاسوء عاصفه ثلجيه من اربعه
عقود الغاء الفي رحله جويه يؤثر على ثلاثه
ملايين مسافر
شكرا لكم لطيب المتابعه واترككم في رعايه
الله وحفظها القاكم على راس الساعه
[موسيقى]